si monsieur chirac a rempli cet après
midi le parc des princes monsieur marche
est rempli lui aussi un autre stade
celui de marseille
reportage bruno albin et alain marseille
cet après midi le stade vélodrome
georges marchais il y a donné l'un des
meetings les plus spectaculaires de
toute sa campagne électorale
devant un public que le parti communiste
estime à 50 mille personnes
j'ai parlé avec des habitués de
l'olympique de marseille et des belles
heures du stade vélodrome ils m'ont dit
que ce chiffre de 50 mille personnes
n'étaient probablement pas exagérer un
meeting est la mesure de la force du
parti communiste dans cette région un
discours-fleuve prononcée par un georges
marchais survoltée deux temps forts dans
son intervention la réduction du temps à
partir la campagne officielle à la radio
et la télévision
c'est inacceptable dit georges marchais
l'autre passage concernant l'attitude
des socialistes face à l'éventualité
d'un gouvernement d'union après les
élections georges marchais accuse le
maire socialiste de marseille gaston
defferre compte pouvoir se dispenser
d'inclure les communistes dans la
majorité parlementaire et dans le
gouvernement
après avoir obtenu leur voix pour faire
élire les députés socialistes et d'autre
part ils ans la façade d'un gouvernement
quasi socialiste renforcé de transfuges
giscardien est bien réfléchie et flic
gésù bien et cela avec réalise tout cela
ne peut avoir qu'un sens puisque le
parti socialiste ne pourra pas gouverner
seul gaston defferre annonce en fait une
proposition gouvernementale des
socialistes avec la droite
la france a déjà connu cela
c'est une impasse demain l'invité
d'antenne de midi sera monsieur roland
leroy qui est le directeur du journal
l'humanité monsieur mitterrand est élu
aujourd'hui dans la région du languedoc
roussillon dernière étape ce soir
perpignan
un reportage de bernard pradines haut et
jean françois renaud sur place